λόγο του των προσωπικών δεδομένω δεν μπορούμε εμεις γιατρί να είναι ενημερώσουε τους δασκάλους τους
κατηκίτές των παιδιών και υπάρχει ένα γεννικώ πρόβλημαν σε αυτά τα παιδιά και αντιμετωπίζω σοβαρών
σοβαρών κοινωνικών ξκακαντιμή σοβαρά κοινωνικά προβλήματα και στη γερμανία για αυτόν των λόγων ίδρισα και
ξεκίνησα το επάρχει επαγγερμανικάν το σύλογον παιδιών καρκοινοπαθών γονέωκαι προσπαθήσαμε σε ατόν να δώσουμε διεξόδος
να μιλήσουμε με τους γονίς πως θα αντιμετοοποίήσουν τα προβλήματα τ παιδιώντους και να δηιοργσυμε
πλιστα και σε μενάρια και οργανώσουμε κάποιες και διαλέξεις και εκδυλώσεις και σε μινάρια και
για τα παιδιά και για τους γονίσουν τας ώστες αυτόν να βοηθήθούν είναι αντεράστιων πρόβλημα
ναυτ και νομίζω ότι οπωςδήποτε είναι από τα επόμενα θέματα τα οποία θέλουμε αποροίδρημα μας
να σχοληθούμε σοβαρά γιατρέ γιατί ακόμη δεν βρήκαμε τη θεναπία ανακαλήφθηκαν τόσα πράγματα ο κόσμος
όπως λέμε πήγε στο θεγκάγιατί για αυτή την ασθενεία ακόμη δεν έχει βρεθεί το φάρμακο
ώστε να μηχανώται τος έσες ίσως είναι πολί πολλά τα λεφτα όχι εσείς εμιλήσεται φυσικά
είναι αλλά σείς εμιλήσεται για μία ανασθένεια δεν είναι μία ασθένεια είναι πάρα πολλές οι
ασθένειες των κακοηθειών και μάλιστα όσον εξετάζουμε και τα γονιδιώματα των καϊκοηθιών κιτάρων